Daniel: Right.
All right.
For the next interval, we are in the
section hosted by the Active Inference
Institute on our recent paper, active
Inference Institute and the Active
Inference Ecosystem.
So two short messages.
First, if you're in the live chat, I'll
post the link right now to the paper.
And this can be more of like a
conversational interval.
So if you have any questions about the
ecosystem or the institute or any of the
stuff that we're talking about, let's
make it a conversation.
And then second message.
If there are any co authors on this paper
who are listening to this stream, then
message me on discord or post in the
YouTube live chat or just check your
calendar, and I expect some others to
join in as we go.
Welcome, Pablo.
We'll be hearing in a little bit from you
as a presenter.
Is there anything that you want to just
bring up or reflect on before I share the
screen with the paper and we just walk
through it, explore it and hear
questions?
It okay.
I'll bring in the paper.
And again, anyone watching live, please
just feel free to write any questions,
and I'm just going to bring it so that
Pablo.
You're not going to see the paper, but it'
's on the live stream.
All right, cool.
Well, here we go.
This is a paper that had an awesome co
authorship and even broader circles
beyond the listed co authors of
collaboration and contribution.
So just like everything that has happened
and will happen in our work, it was
massively participatory and a real
learning by doing and a real enactment
moment.
The first version was released three days
ago on Saturday, August 19, and I'll
briefly just list all the authors.
First, we had the institute as the first
author so that the citation can always
remain like institute et al.
Institute, comma active Inference
institute.
And we also had Andrea Guire, John Boyk,
Lieber Burian, matthew Brown, RJ Corday,
scott David david S.
Douglas, Pablo Fernandez Macchia, Daniel
Friedman, holly Grimm, Avele Gwynen,
carlo Maria, Louisa Ayenico, virginia
Blue Knight, alexandra Mikhailova, Ali
Ramju Adil Razi, jacob Smith, rene Tamari,
, dean Tickles and Alex Viakin.
So this includes everyone from founders
and officers and board of directors and
formal participants on different projects
and different roles as volunteers or
facilitators or interns, and also people
who are continuing to join the fun and
show up and makes the institute in our
field what it is and what it can be, what
we want it to be.
There's a table of contents for those who
like to click through.
And just broadly, there's going to be a
preamble on active inference.
But outside of the preamble, this paper
is not conceptual, it is not technical,
it is not philosophical, although perhaps
it can be read in all of those ways, but
it's quite a logistical, historical, and
vision oriented position document.
After getting some of the active
inferences out of the way in the preamble.
.
We're going to turn to the institute
itself in terms of our vision, values,
principles, and how we see moving through
the challenges that we're facing right
now onto the specific history of the
institute, our current organization model
in terms of our governance and leadership
structure, as well as the institute units,
, the organizational units that support
all the work we do.
We then turn out to the community and
ecosystem growth and development and go
through some details of different roles
that our stakeholders and participants in
our space and some of the tools that we
use today for managing information and
message passing.
We talk a little bit about our
communications plan, internal and
external, both sides of the blanket, and
point towards some of the types of
support, infrastructure and
administration that we do and that we
will offer for the active inference
ecosystem.
We frame that in terms of continual
deployment, continual development and
quality, performance and growth
evaluations across multiple scales, close
with some discussion and then provide an
appendix that overviews a variety of the
open source services that the Institute
has provided over the past.
So let's just jump in.
I'm actually going to jump into the open
source services first and overview them
before we jump back up to the top and
look at the big picture.
Because this is really to appreciate the
work of so many contributors who stepped
up in the uncanny valley, in the gray
zone, in the ecosystem, as it's forming,
as it's always forming, and really made
it happen.
And so many people we know are out there
scribbling or taking notes or printing
out papers by Friston at all or
struggling and asking questions, are
there applications of this?
How would this matter?
Why would this matter?
Is there a code version of this?
How do you connect the dots between
these?
Like, those are what we ask every day.
And so when people can combine their
regimes of attention into a synthetic
intelligence outcome, then we go so far.
So the first category of works that the
Institute has developed are educational.
We've done video live streams since the
end of 2020.
Till now, more than 370 live streams.
All live streams are curated in terms of
their transcript.
And we increasingly are developing
automated and semiautomated methods for
transcription, translation, sub,
captioning, language modeling and so on.
We've had textbook groups actually.
Now, as of now, we have three completed
cohorts of the active inference textbook
group, the 2022 textbook.
We have two courses that are being
offered that are produced by external
content developers, and both of these
have only started in the last three, four
months.
First is Chris Fields's, physics is
Information Processing, and second is the
work spearheaded by Avel and co organized
with Kairos Research, active inference in
the social sciences.
Both of these are like awesome and great
learning experiences, as we heard from
earlier in the symposium.
We're working with Sanjeev Namjoshi on
his incredible textbook, although almost
to call it a textbook is to either think
more broadly about textbooks than one has
or constrain what it really is that he's
doing, because it's such a unique, real
research development, full spectrum
effort.
So I'm really looking forward to seeing
how this plays out in 2024.
Until then, for those who want to get
involved with the testing that we do and
we've developed the Active Inference
Ontology, which is a critical resource
for the ecosystem.
It enables us to center accessibility,
rigor and applicability across languages
and settings by knowing what it is that
we're talking about when we talk about
active inference.
On the research side, we've also
developed the Ontology in a research
direction in terms of research on and
about and with active inference itself.
As far as software goes, our primary
development, first off, has been the
documentation and connecting the dots
around some of these other incredible
packages that others are developing.
For example, just in this symposium, we'
've heard from some of the core
developers and open source contributors
to Pymdp, the Python package for
generative modeling, as well as just a
couple of minutes ago from Bert de Fryes
and Dmitry Bagueev coming from the Julia
language RX and FIR side.
And both of those are some of the leading
packages for applying active inference.
So we do a lot of work to connect those
dots and make it more accessible.
Not everybody is going to jump in with
all 6ft to a programming language.
And what we've done with Active
Blockfriends, with the work of Jacob
Smekal and others, is to wrap generative
models from active inference inside of
the complex systems modeling framework
Catcat.
We've developed notation interoperability
systems that actually let us pull back
one layer from the implementational
details themselves, for example, of RX
infer or of Pymdp, so that we can bring
it halfway to where the ontology and the
visualization and the natural language
exists, and then use language models and
other techniques to deploy it in an
implementation fashion.
We've developed a host of research
publications.
We support people in all of their
different stages of their career,
different seasons of life, and some
really creative work has been directly
produced through an institute project or
somebody who knows may have gotten good
ideas or good feedback just by hanging
out, being in the game.
And we performed literature metaanalyses
to help grapple with the scope and the
quantity and the quality of what is
unfolding before our eyes or before our
antenna.
Again, even as we only so partially
sample this ocean of information, we're
active in standard setting and continue
to develop our qualification standards
for active inference that could be the
basis of education, research and
professional development.
We provide a variety of mentorship and
facilitation service type activities,
including volunteer program, internship
program, distributed facilitation, and
applied active inference symposia.
These activities, just as all others that
we're describing above, are open source,
and they're also open to your
participation.
So if you can follow some of those
suggestions by JF time boxing and
prioritize and pay attention and be
active, all those fun things that he said,
, and you're looking to do it in a semi
structured way with a volunteer program,
or in a more structured way with the
internship, then I heartily encourage
people to get involved.
Act now.
And in terms of governance activity, we
have a scientific advisory board as well
as a board of directors.
And together with the officers, those
groups constitute the formal governance
structure of the Institute.
But there's also so much more to it, and
we look forward to understanding what
ecosystem governance can look like in the
coming years.
So welcome, Dean.
I just summarized the work itself.
That was the preamble.
And now if you'd like to say hi, you or
Pablo, before we jump into more sections
of the paper or look at more questions
that people have asked, how goes it?
Or what was your experience of working
with the paper?
Or what brings you onto this strange
stream at this opportune time?
Dean: Basically why I'm here is because
for the first time, even as an acting
board member with the Institute, I was
able to get a better sense of the kind of
depth that we aspire to.
And I'm not sure whether or not we are
going to be I really don't know what
directions we're going to be going in the
next coming months, weeks, years, et
cetera.
But I have a better sense now, as a
result of participating in this
development exercise, of what the
potential is than I probably had at any
time.
And I've been with the Active Inference
Institute for a couple of years, so that'
's saying something.
I think we had to get to this point to be
able to write this document, and now it's
acting as a bit of a springboard now
which way we go and how we land.
I'm not still certain about what that
looks like, but I think that's part of
what the really interesting thing is.
We seem to have moved away from the dock,
and now the real journey begins.
So that's my take on it so far.
Daniel: Moving away from the dock, dock
pushing off, using it as a springboard,
continuing the adventure, leaving the
preprint behind, continuing to version it
as a living document and also wayfinding
outside of the doc.
Dean: Pablo.
Daniel: Oh, wait, I don't hear you yet.
Pablo.
Pablo: Sorry, I was mute.
Hello.
It was a great experience to go through
the document and review it and reread it
and thinking about it.
Actually, it's a living document, which
is super exciting, and I keep taking
notes and hopefully act on it in the
future.
And it's been a super experience to find
so many people with the same interest,
same interest and some values that I
really think are going to be the basis of
organizations on the future.
So I think we are doing something very
cool here.
Daniel: Cool.
All right, well, let's just walk through
some of the sections in the 25 minutes
that we have.
Again, the paper is being shown on the
stream, but Dean And probably don't see
it.
So we kicked off with a preamble.
We wanted to introduce active inference
as briefly as we could and point towards
the fundamental first principles and
physics based nature of active inference
and initially point towards its
integrative capacity in principle.
And then in the second paragraph, there's
about 104 citations in this paragraph.
And that's where it's really only a
sampling of the domains, 21 domains here.
.
So it's a place where we can point to
where is active inference being applied,
or how is active inference being applied,
or how is it different or better than
another approach in a given setting?
Which isn't to say that it does
everything in all settings for all people
at all times and all of that, but this is
to say that here's where one can look to
find out more and even just building.
This and bringing it all together.
We see so many opportunities for
epistemic resources in the ecosystem and
having real time literature analyses and
all these kinds of services that we want
to provide.
Starting on page five, we turn to the
institute itself and we write as of
August 2023, the Active Inference
Institute is a registered nonprofit
organization tasked with identifying,
establishing, and managing the
sustainable implementation of
administrative and governance functions
to give components of the active
inference ecosystem coherent forms and
reliable channels of communication.
Two, publishing and licensing protocols
that establish open and fair use and
effective dissemination of community
products within and beyond the ecosystem.
.
Three, services at the scale of
individual humans and the community at
large so that stability is protected
while risk and uncertainty are minimized
within the ecosystem.
And four, organization and operation of
cyber and cognitive security systems that
ensure productivity, inclusivity
accessibility, and safety in discourse.
In collaboration, figure one gives a
graphical representation, just one of how
we are now.
And for those who want to dig more, check
out the 2022 Active Inference textbook
where you'll also find a golden ring.
And we kind of took that graphical motif
and ran with it.
Had a lot of fun and a lot of
interpretations there.
So just here looking at figure one, Dean
or Pablo just want to add anything?
Yeah, Dean.
Dean: So one thing about the building of
this document with a whole bunch of
authors, it's often not made explicit,
but there are two aspects to learning
about yourself.
One is to actually throw some stuff down
on paper because you believe certain
things need to be included.
And then the second part is the
consolidation process.
And I think one of the most interesting
consolidation processes was this graphic,
because I think what it does is it tries
to condense as much as possible and yet
still remain coherent around what the
relational aspects that we are trying to
make available are, as opposed to, this
is what we've captured.
Now look what our graphic designer came
up with.
So if you've had a chance to kind of look
at this and really analyze it and think
about the layers and think about, okay,
so what's the background here?
What's the foreground?
Does this representation allow for a
swapping?
Can we have things that appear to be
background or fundamental basis stuff
that could actually be things that we are
addressing in the moment versus those
things which we look at as particulars,
that, in fact, are generalities?
So, again, it's one of those things.
I don't know.
Daniel probably knows whether it's a
Where's Waldo's thing or some sort of
artist that came up with some strange
twist on things.
But the bottom line is, spend a few
minutes, have a look, because you'll want
to go through your own building of what
these relationships are, and you'll also
want to be able to consolidate.
I wasn't there when this representation
was built, but I do know that I want to
be able to both look at it, do a
comparative analysis to what I think the
Institute should be, and then be able to
consolidate.
Daniel: Awesome.
Yeah.
Just a few notes on this and to give a
visual overview, since it may be clearer
to see this than go through the prose
that essentially describes it as much
later on.
The golden ring represents the active
inference ecosystem, and I think we could
talk about golden rings for a long time
to come.
But coming in from the ecosystem on the
bottom bottom for the reader, not from
the other side of the table, are the
projects.
And all the projects are participatory
endeavors.
They're happening behind, on, and in
front of the golden ring, depending on
how you look at it.
And that is the appendix and all of those
different projects that we talked about
and all of the iterations and new threads
that I know that we're going to see in an
hour and I know that we're going to see
in a month and in a year and in a century.
.
And those projects are being supported
through two units, kind of like a
department, but an organizational unit,
one centered on education and one
centered on research.
The education unit is called Educe, and
the research unit is called Reinforce.
So right there you kind of have active
inference, in case that wasn't clear
coming from the Institute scale.
Supporting the unit scale are a variety
of functions such as funding and
partnerships, communications and
hierarchical processes such as the
construction of enabling systems.
And at the institute scale, other than
administrative functions.
We have the officers, the day to day
operators of the work, the board of
directors, which is the formal governing
body, and the scientific advisory board
where we really want to call out broadly
and have people who may have or may have
not thought that they would find
themselves in a scientific advisory board,
, for example, in 2024.
This is your invitation.
And we really want to have a vibrant
scientific advisory board who serves
liaison type roles with different sectors
and just gives periodic, super valuable,
high leverage insight.
And then, I guess, depending on how you
think about it, as all things we have
just a few terms.
They don't just represent bricks in the
wall, but it's more of like the fibers we
weave.
And some of these are already things that
we do every day courses, educational
groups, events, live streams, ontology
research.
Others of these are things that we know
will be coming into place in the coming
years and we know that the tapestry is
just going to continue to expand.
So it's really exciting.
On Page Six, we have another figure and
this is just another way to represent
some of the functions that we serve in
the ecosystem.
This isn't the only or the final or a
fixed representation of the functions
that we have or the only way to slice and
dice or any of that, but just to connect
some of the dots between the functions
that we do and want to serve for the
ecosystem.
So starting from the broadest, let's just
say where the listener is, where you are
right now is in the space of awareness.
And that happens through communication.
Some people who become aware through a
search or a language model or a video
suggestion or a friend or happenstance or
synchronicity or however, some fraction
of the aware will pursue education.
And about education we have and will
continue to produce the materials,
documentation ontology courses, live
streams and so on.
Education is produced and rests upon a
commons.
It's an epistemic commons.
It's a verified information environment.
And that is really the space.
The wildlife preserve, as I know Dean
likes to refer to it not jokingly at all.
.
And underneath the commons is the support
that does sit between a participatory
commons and a formal governing kernel.
That support in the coming years may go
many directions, but we know it's going
to involve all of our favorite things
like hardware, software, information,
behavior, narrative, and more.
And then we have the regular institute
scale governance, partnership sponsor and
donor relationships such that we can
first find a type of stability or
sustainability and then more actively
play a regenerative role in our ecosystem.
.
We want to dispense micro grants to
people and we want to explore paid
internships and be able to meet people
where they are in their active inference
journey.
And things have been happening to that
end and through many means since 2021.
On page six.
Pablo or Dean want to add any thoughts?
Pablo: I'm super excited about the
governance, the education on the game and
tools.
Daniel: In an hour we're going to see the
first active inference game.
This is very fun.
On seven, we describe our vision, our
values and our principles.
And just to read the top level on the
values and principles, they are active
inference and exploration, integrity and
inclusivity, dynamic internal modeling,
anticipatory behavior, and continuous
development.
On page eight, we talk about some
priorities and challenge areas.
These are challenges across multiple
scales.
They're challenges that individual people
face in their journey to learn and apply
in so many different backgrounds.
These are challenges of national interest.
.
These are challenges of global emergency
as well.
These challenges are educational in
nature, for example, related to
scientific literacy and workforce
development and just general
professionalization in changing times.
On the research side, there are some
priorities and challenge areas related to
the fundamentals of cognitive science and
grounding the cognitive science in
physics, getting that integrative first
principles framework that we expect and
prefer about information science and
diverse intelligences.
Things are faster and different than they
have been, and active inference is
perfectly poised for sense making and
decision making in that space.
User experience, accessibility, and
sociotechnical design.
This is a major open question across
different settings, so it's not uniquely
held to the institute.
However, we really do believe and really
will commit to exploring new kinds of
ergonomics and onboardings and experience
so that we can come through and be how we
want to be.
From the first time somebody enters the
game.
Where we can highlight accessibility,
meeting people in the language that they
prefer to listen to and speak at the
language, in computer language or at the
math level that reflects somebody's
preference in that moment as well as
being able to use augmented and synthetic
intelligence systems to ramp up and even
push the frontier of what augmented
people and other kinds of collective
intelligence systems can do.
Cyber and cognitive security, these also
are broader topics.
We've worked on these topics from an
active inference perspective.
Many have.
And we think that this is going to become
increasingly relevant as things do become
more and more challenging and uncertain
in certain ways out there.
Scaling the active inference ecosystem we'
've heard about this from the narrow and
technical side.
We had estimates of the computational
complexity of sophisticated inference
about how many computer operations have
to happen for a given calculation to play
out.
And that's sometimes called scaling.
Active inference, like, okay, it took 1
minute on 1GB of data, so how many
minutes is it going to take on this
computer with this much data?
Scaling the active inference ecosystem,
though, is a broader question, and that's
where we come to more of the social
fabric and the real sense of belonging
that we all want to have and co create
and provide for others in the ecosystem.
And so this kind of scaling is really
transdisciplinary.
It's really skin in the game.
It's as real as it gets.
And applying active inference, some
applications we've heard from today, some
applications are cited in the early pages
of this paper, and more and more come
through every day, and we support at the
Institute various applications of active
inference.
Dean, what can you add in there?
Dean: Okay, my mute is off.
Good.
So here's something that never came up in
the writing of the document, but I think
it's kind of interesting, and I'm curious
what you guys have to think about this.
175 years ago, an institution came and
formed together.
It's called the Smithsonian Institute.
Now, I don't know if 175 years from this
conversation today, they'll be the
equivalent of whatever the Active
Inference Institute is 175 years forward,
but I think it's okay to start thinking
in those terms.
It doesn't mean that we follow in their
footsteps, necessarily, but I think it
means that we have a long term view and
that the things that we write about
ourselves now have some shelf life, have
some real sense of, well, there are
things that we can and we cannot change.
But if you look at the front page, the
landing page of the Smithsonian Institute,
, the first thing that they say is
welcome, which is what we say about the
Active Inference Institute.
And then they say, the Smithsonian
Institution is the world's largest museum
education and research complex.
We are a community of learning and an
opener of doors.
Join us on a voyage of discovery.
So in three sentences, they kind of sum
themselves up, what's the formula for not
just existing for 175 years, but being a
force?
And I think, again, Daniel, whatever you
decide to highlight in the document today,
, what I think we're really trying to do
is say, do the words that we put out now,
will they continue to resonate with
people for decades to come?
And again, I don't want to sound all hand
wavy, but I want to hold up an example of
a place that really did set itself up to
be something that people could return to
again and again and again.
And I don't think there's anything wrong
with aspiring to having that kind of
place, that kind of respect.
And I think that the things that you're
pointing to right now, hopefully we're
preparing properly.
So that's what I'm taking away at this
point.
Daniel: We know about that preparation
measurement cycle from Chris Fields, don'
't we?
Dean: Yeah.
Daniel: We go on, talk a little.
Oh, yeah.
Please, Pablo.
Pablo: Go.
No, no, definitely.
I completely agree.
I've been thinking about that for a long
time.
You want to build and act for the best of
the future, and I think to reflect that
on the paper, it's super important.
Yeah, definitely up to do that.
Daniel: Yeah, way ahead.
We describe some paths that we want to
take and the history of the Institute.
We describe our origins.
But I actually wanted to come to figure
three and four on page eleven to speak to
building one of the most amazing and
encouraging things has been the all ages,
all time zone, active build, contribute
mindset.
An earlier version of myself, I might
have thought, like people who do
variational Bayesian methods in machine
learning, they're going to have no issue
onboarding to active inference.
It's just going to be like as simple as
saying, yeah, it's a variational Bayesian
model with action.
So it's just signal processing on the
inbound.
It's just control theory on the outbound.
.
But if you're familiar with variational
Bayes and variational free energy, this
isn't changing it that much.
Oh, yeah, we use a particular partition
and it's related to the free energy
principle.
But don't worry too much, you'll get
there.
I thought that that would be the path for
so many and future analyses will reveal
what they do or don't reveal, but what we
found in our enacted work as it really
played out that there was inclusion and
unique contributions to conversations
ranging from philosophy of science to
fundamentals of statistics and
metascience and the role of quantitative
studies and social systems.
All these amazing topics and people who
just scampered so rapidly through what
could be seen as prerequisite from a
disciplinary perspective was facilitated
by the recognition that one was already
in the space and in the way that they
needed to be to be an active inference.
And that was not written out before and
even now the traces are barely recorded,
but it will become to be understood more
fully.
Dean: And to your point, Daniel, I think
especially what the pie chart shows is
the actual spectrum aspect of this.
So I know that right now that maybe the
neuroscience and the psychology piece
take up a bigger portion.
But I think one of the things that we're
trying to promote is the idea that you
can come from just about any background
as opposed to, oh, all paths lead to, as
you said, an earlier version of you said,
oh, okay, well, I can see where
everything is going to where the
confluence is going to.
No, I think what this demonstrates is
that it's actually becoming more
distributed the longer we continue to
exist.
Daniel: Yeah, this figure, of course, I'm
super happy with everything that we were
able to do, but this figure is almost a
little bit like a paper target that we're
just going to blow out later.
Because it was a fraction of only people
who had formal affiliations listed, which
means only people for whom we had done
full literature based pulling up their
information.
So it doesn't even represent the actual
participation profile.
This is more like the invitation list for
live streams.
So we are going to see another long tail
that covers the part that's not the long
tail.
I believe the rest of the paper continues
along possibilities, challenges, next
steps, more about the institute
organization, various other pieces of
information that potentially eager
stakeholders or participants or donors or
liaisons or other people would like to
learn more about.
It's there to engage with.
We want people to hop into our discord
and continue the conversation or email us
or otherwise get involved.
It's why we called this symposium
enacting Ecosystems of Shared
Intelligence at the, of course, relevant
suggestion of Karl Friston, because we
really do want to enact it.
So if you feel like you're on the
sideline waiting to jump in or you're on
the beach and people are out there
surfing the 100 foot wave, then maybe it'
's time to get more involved.
So I will leave the closing word first to
Dean, then Pablo, and then we'll go to
Raph's presentation.
Dean: Well, just real quick, again, if
you want a consolidated document that
speaks to the now but also points to a
direction that none of us really know is
certain, but is also really exciting,
have a look at the doc.
Daniel: Pablo?
Pablo: Yeah.
I'm here to make sure that I act as one
of those people of all backgrounds and
perspectives that has taken advantage
through one year of learning and working
on this institute, and hopefully see you
in 1 hour.
So thank you and have fun.
Dean: Thanks.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dean.
Thank you, Pablo.